with over 300 sessions at next 2018 it's
understandable you can get to them all
so if you didn't see leverage AI on the
cloud to transform your business then
stay tuned because here's the rewind
machine learning is an algorithmic
approach to making repeated decisions
with data so check that you have all
those components before you begin data
to learn from check access to machine
learning algorithms check desired
automate repeated decisions and we're
really talking repetition here not 10
decisions but more like 10,000 or 10
billion check great let's dive in and
summarize the four big ideas from the
talk first ml can be used to solve many
problems for which you're writing rules
today in fact a great way to find
opportunities to apply it is to look for
rules in your business for example query
completion in Google search used to be a
real tangle of handcrafted rules
applying machine learning to it brought
a biggest boost in ranking quality in
over two years
secondly machine learning is how you
personalize your applications because ml
scales better than those handcrafted
rules and it lets you layer models on
top of your existing logic you can now
also delight folks who are unlike your
main user contingent now of course what
makes all this tick is data you can
think of ml as turning that rules-based
process on its head
instead of starting with the model or
rules flip it to start with your data
thirdly design systems with the
expectation that you will have more more
more data next year your world is in
static and you should expect that your
data will grow this is a great thing
because more data wins but what happens
when this puts you in the realm of
exabytes or petabytes
for example deep learning only works
well with large data sets to drop your
error rate linearly you're gonna have to
increase your data exponentially that's
a log scale over there like predictions
if you're into deep learning
I predict lots of data in your future so
here's a suggestion don't spend all your
personal time on big data infrastructure
instead take a serverless approach so
you can put your effort into what
actually brings you the most value
think in terms of code not
infrastructure which brings us to our
fourth idea use a platform but lets you
forget about infrastructure and offers
great pre-built models look for
flexibility for different ml scenarios
so let's revisit deep learning the
compute power needed to do
state-of-the-art machine learning went
up 10 million times in the last six
years 10 million times whoa if you want
to be on the cutting edge you're gonna
need an efficient cost-effective ml
environment to handle more and more data
you're gonna need to go distributed to
handle more and more compute you're
going to need better Hardware Google
Cloud brings you the ideal environment
for distributed processing on Hardware
tailored to your needs it gives you a
fantastic fully managed server this way
to run ml with great pre-built models
you don't need to build everything from
scratch if you don't want to I mean why
are we invent wheels you don't have to
reinvent right in summarizing this talk
for you I left out the colorful use
cases that really bring those ideas to
life meet machine learning from movie
recommender systems fraud detection
customer service the Internet of Things
car auctions gaming and more if you'd
like to see the full talk check out the
link in the description below and don't
forget to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
[Music]